if you're planning to travel to Germany
this Easter weekend make sure you're up
to date on the latest restrictions on
movement Austin that's four million for
millions of Christians Easter is going
to church spending Easter Sunday with
the whole family
maybe a walk and Easter bonfire for many
it's also short vacation at the seaside
in the south where it's already warmer
usually but not this year
Abin East Indies Mia with social contact
already limited within Germany the
government's Crisis Group agreed on
Monday to institute a two-week
quarantine for attorneys so who's
affected as of April 10th all German
nationals EU citizens and other longtime
residents who returned to Germany after
several days abroad have to quarantine
themselves for 14 days
there are however exceptions seasonal
workers in agriculture commuters
traveling to work truck drivers
delivering goods and of course medical
professionals restrictions for non
Germans and non residents have already
been in place since mid-march only those
with a valid reason to travel can be
admitted to Germany for everyone else
the same message applies it's time to
stay at home DW political correspondent
Hans Brandt joins me now from our
parliamentary studio Hans Germany is
increasing restrictions for residents
entering the country yet at the same
time there have been discussions about
how and when to start easing the
lockdown is that not a contradiction yes
on the face of it there is a
contradiction there in the numbers in
Germany have been encouraging in the
last few days there are still increasing
numbers of infected people of sick
people infected with the virus but this
increase is slowing down so there is
some sense that possibly in Germany the
peak of this may have been overcome but
at the same time the German authorities
seem very remain very concerned that the
restrictions that have been in place
remain in place that people don't get
the feeling that now that spring is
coming now that things seem to
be looking a little bit more positive
that now that holidays are starting
school holidays and so on now might be
the time actually to leave their homes
and to travel or whatever and at the
same time residents from neighboring
countries might feel that well in
Germany you know that's more open to
movement more open to having a holiday
in Germany that's I think why these
restrictions are being impersonal one
does not want to risk that the
achievements that the progress has been
made in recent weeks is in some way you
know lost quickly this weekend there's
Easter weekend hunts looking at the
German economy the government has
already paid out billions in aid to
businesses and further billions are
promised yet today even more aid was
announced why yes this concerns a
special section of the of the companies
small and medium companies who are not
entitled to direct support from the
government direct payments from the
government they have to apply for soft
learns from their banks and these loans
are guaranteed by the German state and
apparently there has been some
reluctance by banks who have to take
some of the risk for these loans by
banks actually to to approve these loans
a lot of companies who have made
applications seem not to be able to push
them through as quickly as possible so
the German state has now said that it
will take over the entire risk for such
soft loans and is then occurring the
banks with these new with these new
measures to try and speed up the process
so that business this businesses can get
money quickly our political
correspondent Hans blunt thank you
lockdowns surveillance even arrests EU
governments are taking a host of
measures to curb the spread of the
coronavirus that would have seemed
impossible just weeks ago such
restrictions on civil liberties are
deemed a matter of life and death now
but activists worry that when the crisis
is over emergency measures could become
long-term fixtures
this is Europe and a lotta measures that
are unprecedented in peacetime are now
in place to combat covert 19 we have
seen across Europe governments and and
across the world indeed implementing
measures that even a month ago would
have been unimaginable to many of us
some already fear that the measures
could outlast the coronavirus crisis
what is a big question is when this
whole thing ends what we will be left
with Europe 750 million residents have
already seen their rights of freedom of
movement heavily restricted breaking the
rules can mean fines people diagnosed
with Kovac 19 in Italy for example could
face prison time if they break Carentan
are the measures been taken around
Europe a less visible mobile carriers
are sharing data with health authorities
in countries like Italy Germany and
Austria to help authorities monitor
whether people are following rules
the data is anonymized but data leak at
Austria elf ministry website has already
raised privacy concerns many European
leaders are stressing that the new
measures are limited in time an initial
period of 30 days for at least 15 days
after Easter but one country is heading
down a more radical path Hungary the
country's parliament has endorsed a bill
giving Nationalist Prime Minister Viktor
Orban the power to indefinitely extend a
state of emergency and rule by decree
it's kind of suspicious why can't they
say okay guys I need you know three
months now after three months we can get
together and see whether it's justified
to prolong it meanwhile another EU
country France offers an example of how
emergency measures can stick around
longer than anticipated after the terror
attacks in Paris
in 2015 the government declared a state
of emergency and sheõs have criticized
the fact that these exceptional powers
were later written into law experts say
the corona crisis calls for emergency
measures but what structs are urging
caution one of the UN Special
Rapporteurs tweeted we may survive the
health crisis but if we don't tend to
our own democracies we have lost the war
well halfway I'm now joined by Catarina
barley she's a former Minister of
Justice here in Germany and currently
one of the vice presidents of the
European Parliament do you agree with
the statement we just heard can some of
the emergency measures that are being
introduced now amount to a threat to
democracy absolutely and the examples
were well chosen especially Hungary
there already was the possibility to to
rule by decree for the head of
government but you had to come back to
the Parliament after 15 days and have
the measures confirmed by the Parliament
and the opposition even offered to
extend this to 30 days they would have
probably said 60 days to but Albin
insisted on an indefinite prolongation
and that of course raises a lot of
concerns regarding what he has done
before and regarding that there is still
a state of emergency out of 2015 the
refugee crisis whereas we know that
Hungary doesn't welcome any any refugees
and it is still in place since 2015 well
you said you concerned about what Albin
is doing in Hungary but what's the or
the --use reaction to that well the the
parents of the European Union did not
foresee that even to member states could
get into conflict with the European
values so we do have the article 7
procedure but it has to end with a
unanimous decision may all the other
member states now having Poland
supporting Hungary that this won't get
us any further so at the moment the only
weapon that we have is the European
Court of Justice which is doing its job
but we do need more measures especially
financial ones you mentioned Poland
there supporting hungry is their
appetite among other EU countries to
leave some of the measures in place even
when the crisis is over yes this is not
only something that is specific to to
the new illiberal the lot of democracies
as they call them this is something that
governments tend to do to keep power to
themselves that they have taken from the
government's so we have to be aware of
this in all the Member States and anyway
we as a European Union are going to
introduce a rule of law mechanism to do
a monitoring every year and we will have
a very close look at this specifically
but looking at the EU on the whole it
still seems there is no real coordinated
approach and Italy anger is mounting of
the lack of solidarity in among EU
states has the EU failed in tackling
this crisis no the U was late to start I
admit that it should have been a lot
earlier two together the heads of
government but you have to admit that
the European Union itself does not have
very many competences in these fields of
Health of education of security of
social systems so you can't ask for the
European unity to act but not give it
the competence is necessary we have to
talk about what we actually want the
European Union to be and to do after
this crisis is over and then to give it
the competences it needs it needs
therefore so how do you will you rate
the EU coronavirus response you're quite
happy with it no as I said it started
too late
but then the European Union mainly can
coordinate that is what they are doing
at the moment there are common
acquisitions for medical devices for
medical materiel there are measures
concerning the common market there are
measures concerning the finances for
most of all and but as I said especially
concerning
the social systems concerning health I
think we really need more competences if
not the EU is only a coordinator hmm
Catarina Bali vice-president of the EU
Parliament talking us from her home
thank you very much but we're staying in
the UK where the coronavirus had not
only shocked down much of the country
but also seen a boom in conspiracy
theories one that's been growing on
social media networks is a belief that
5g mobile phone technology is somehow
linked to this outbreak in Britain it's
led to some phone transmission mass
being vandalized and even set on fire
our reporter Alex Forrest whiting joins
me now with more on that Alex tell us
more about these these attacks yes as
you say a number of phone masts across
the UK have been targeted in recent
weeks and particularly the end of last
week with some set on fire filmed and
put on social media websites such as
Twitter and they've also been reports of
engineers who've been trying to lay
fiber-optic cables being harassed on the
streets and accused of killing people
now you may wonder what is the link
between 5g technology and the
coronavirus where there are some
unsubstantiated claims that radiation
comes from this technology that it can
hurt people's health and that it can
lower people's immune systems now that
has been the case people have thought
ever since mobile technology first came
on the scene it's being discredited but
since the coronavirus the pandemic has
really hit all of us across the world of
this conspiracy theory has really found
a life of its own particularly focused
on the fact that Wuhan which is was at
the epicenter of the outbreak in China
was the city where the 5g technology was
really tested that's quite a stretch
actually what's been the response to all
this well probably not surprisingly
nonsense from the British government
they said these are
completely unsubstantiated claims and
also from health officials including the
World Health Organization who said
actually these conspiracy theories are
very dangerous because emergency
services are relying on phone technology
to help everyone particularly in this
crisis there's been a lot of pressure
yet again on social media companies to
try to make sure this content is not
seen on their websites only recently we
heard from Facebook's Mark Zuckerberg
who said and I quote that Facebook will
remove false claims and conspiracy
theories that have been flagged by
leading global health organizations but
you don't need to look far to find them
on Facebook you can find these anti 5g
groups and many of the posts are linked
directly to covert 19 Alex Perez Whiting
reporting from Britain there thank you
now let's get you the latest on other
developments related to the global
corona virus pandemic almost 1.3 million
people have been infected with a virus
worldwide that's almost twice as many as
just one week ago more than 70 thousand
have died
Austrian is said to start loosening its
coronavirus lockdown Chancellor
Sebastian quartz announced that smaller
shops could reopen next week restaurants
and hotels would follow in May Romania
extends its state of emergency by
another 30 days beyond current measures
said - in next week the country has so
far confirmed more than 4,000 cases
Russia's caseload jumped by almost 1,000
in 24 hours Moscow remains the epicenter
of the outbreak 47 people have died
across the country